on savait que me les miss ont passé le
test de culture générale à l'île maurice
à lyon la semaine dernière après leur
premier plateau télé les miss se sont
envolés pour l'île maurice avant de
défiler le 15 décembre prochain à lille
pour le titre de miss france 2010 9 et
comme chaque année durant ce voyage les
30 miss régionales ont passé le test de
culture générale mais c'est pas comme
ici pour entrer fois il ya plus de 40
questions qui ont été posées aux miss
elles ont aussi posé en maillot de bain
pour la première fois et on a les photos
en maillot et j'ai deux trois questions
du test de culture générale
je vais voir si vous auriez pu être miss
comme ça à priori physiquement déjà non
mais enfin à part les filles
franchement les gars son nom mais
christine will jabel géraldine les
quatre vous auriez vu qu'elles iront la
qualité des produits merci une escale
est derrière moi forcément je ne les ai
jamais vus tient avant le grand concours
de miss france le 15 décembre prochain à
lille c'est à l'île maurice cette fois
ci que les trente prétendants au trône
de miss france se prépare sous le soleil
au programme sorties en catamaran
tourisme sur l'île et épreuves sportives
en tous genres l'occasion de crier des
slogans qui ont l'air bien mais qu'on a
un peu de mal à comprendre
[Musique]
et puis comme chaque année le comité de
sylvie tellier a fait passer le fameux
test de culture générale aux miss je me
sens est d'illustrer ces cobac
parmi les questions cette énigme est
digne d'une classe de cm2 la mère de
lucie a trois enfants ses deux premières
filles se nomment mary et anna comment
s'appelle son troisième enfant est la
grande gagnante de ce test de culture g
et laurie des rois remis centre val de
loire avec la note de 18 20 35 sur 20
reste à savoir si cette victoire en
pressage du lot
alors les miss france qui passera un
test de culture générale
alors je vous dis j'ai quelques
questions alors vous et vous ça vous
énerve mois vous aurez peut-être mills
où vous auriez pu alors non parce que je
sais depuis l'enfance que g11 un peu un
gros popotin
ben oui mais non match qui me révolte
par contre c'est ce test de culture
générale
parce qu'à un moment donné on est élu on
veut on est en train d'élire une miss
france et la miss france on ne va pas
demander donc flux de de nous dire ce
qu'elle est c'est très dur général s'est
passé non non parce qu'il ya des
fictions pas la chance d'avoir fait si
non laquelle vous avez tous elles
représentent ces soi-disant
l'ambassadrice de la france si elle est
conne c'est emmerdant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendait d'abord d'abord quelle idée
oui j'aimerais juste précisé bernard oui
il ya des codes qui sont très berges et
pas que des stones s'il a dit on qu'on
peut pas laisser une conne mais il ya
des clubs qui sont très belles et
justement match offert une un peu moins
belle mais qui n'est pas conne et qui
est gentil et qui respecte les gens et
la culture générale et becquet de toit
jusqu'à la salade savons sur plusieurs
revendications d'un témoignage donné
deux fils montiel chaque jour vous
repousser les limites de la connerie
[Rires]
eurofer a eu elle se débrouille
invraisemblable ce que vous dites
écoutez kelly c'est discriminant de leur
faire passer ça mettrait vous dites mais
c'est pour déconner et quand on quand on
n'est pas la chance d'avoir fait des
études quand on n'est pas cultivée elle
pourquoi les sélectionner pourquoi
humilier celles qui ne savent pas comme
ça alors quoi ubs hevego l'as docherie
ça vous le savez très bien
je suis entièrement d'accord avec telly
qu'il ne faut supprimer serait de
culture générale qui datent du siècle
dernier
si on veut garder les buts voilà on n'a
aucune humiliation si moi je suis pour
le test de la wii
alors je vous dis alors les questions
par exemple le test de culture générale
par exemple pour pour les miss c'est
qu'elle est la capitale de la pologne
varsovie bien sûr alors qui quelle est
la distance d'un marathon 195 quel est
le plus grand département de france
métropolitaine non c'est la gironde
aussi dit elle c'est la crau polythène
exactement et je vous le dis et enfin
donc l'émission elles ont fait leurs
photos en maillot de bain dans la
piscine de leur hôtel
ainsi que sur l'une des plages de l'île
maurice regardez on a les coulisses de
cette séance photo
regardez voilà au delà de la compétition
des liens se nouent déjà toutes
partagent leurs chambres comme miss
franche comté et miss côte d'azur c'est
nature humaine donc c'est quand même
l'idée assez de parler c'est de partager
s'aider changer sinon on est tout seul
je vis aval prend pas trop de place
elles rentreront en france mercredi
d'ici là court de bonnes manières
d'élégance et surtout leçon de patience
notamment lors de nombreuses séances
photos être une liste sans fin
si vous voulez lire non je les y amener
quelque chose de bien dans ce concours
de culture générale on n'arrête pas de
dire que c'est des potiches qu'elles
servent à rien qu'un sac n'a parlé le
fait qu'elle fasse un test même si c'est
dans les coulisses ça montre qu'elles
sont pas si bonnes que cela mais voilà
c'est à dire que c'est parce que c'est
pas un prétexte aussi pourquoi on est
d'accord après be célesbourg faire un
peu d'exercice